all right please be safe with your own
pets if you can bring them indoors I
would have brought them indoors if I
could have but I couldn't catch up with
them bring your own pets indoors if you
can today it is going to be so hot
outside this morning let's check Valley
temperatures we're in the 80s around the
Las Vegas Valley we finally cooled down
from Henderson even downtown and Green
Valley down into the upper 80s this
morning 83 at Aliante Centennial Hills
you're at 87 so is Sunrise Mountain
Nellis down to 80 so close to 70s the
Lakes at 83 so is Summerlin Mountains
Edge at 86 79 out at Red Rock boy this
is the time this is it if you want to
get out and do a nice big walk around
the block through the neighborhood the
park do a bike ride a jog the morning
hours the this is the time to get that
done because the afternoon is going to
be a dangerous heat for a lot of people
especially if you're on medication the
elderly the very young 74 at Indian
Springs 76 in Pahrump 90 in Laughlin
looking for one teens in Laughlin today
E3 in Mesquite Caliente at 67-48 up in
Ely 68 in Tonopah 67 in Caliente I just
want to give a big shout out to the
ladies at the side track Cafe we drove
through there on Friday and boy what
wonderful food Mary Nicole and Jasmine
thank you so much for your great service
and just friendly so friendly in there
and I'm telling you the food is great at
the side track so good morning to you
they watch every day really really
really appreciate that great place to
eat up there in Caliente what a great
little town too love it 110 today for us
in Las Vegas Caliente 101 for your
afternoon High 105 is the average and
boy July this these are really about the
two hottest weeks every year that we get
and we're going to be very hot 110 Plus
for the start of the week so please
avoid the hottest hours of the day 11
A.M to 5 p.m if you can bring the pets
indoors please do that possible Monsoon
thunderstorms later in the week and then
the end of the week to the weekend just
hot and sticky so the jet stream way up
North that high pressure is expanded
over the west and that Monsoon moisture
steering closer to Arizona today into
Arizona and eventually over our way in
southern Nevada by later in the week 110
111 tomorrow 109 on Wednesday and then
we'll feel the monsoon increase maybe
some thunderstorms or rain on Thursday
slight chances I hope they linger into
Friday otherwise we're just hot and
sticky I think it'll still be still be a
chance in the mountains